graphs of f of t is equal to the natural
log of t plus 5 and h of t is equal to 2
e to the t minus 1 are shown below so
this is f of t right over here this is h
of t right over here drag the variables
to show which equations they must
satisfy there can be any number of
variables per category and some
variables might not go in any category
so what are they talking about well we
have all of these variables here and
they want us to drag it or drag them
into different categories and if we look
at the actual graph we see that these
variables correspond to either the t or
the y coordinate for each of these
points that they've picked out right
over here and so we need to figure out
if you were to in if you were to for
example drag this into this box that
means you believe that 2 e to the t sub
1 minus 1 is equal to the natural log of
t sub 1 plus 5. that this variable if
you substitute it in for t that is going
to make this equation true if for
example you were to substitute this y1
in that means that you think 2e to the y
sub 1 minus 1 is equal to the natural
log of y sub 1 plus 5. and so the three
different buckets that they give us
are essentially setting the two
functions equally to each other setting
two e to the t minus one which was
which was h of t so this is essentially
setting h of t equaling zero and this is
f of t equaling zero so let's take each
of them in turn and i can i copy and
pasted this onto my scratch pad so that
we can work through the math
so the first case that they had was
setting these two things being equal to
each other so for what t's or what can
we substitute in for t so that the
natural log of t plus 5
is equal to
2 e to the t
minus 1. that's another way of saying
for what values of t is f of t
is f of t
this is another way for what values of t
is f of t going to be equal to
going to be equal to
h of t
well two functions are equal to each
other at a given t is if you put that t
in they both give you the same function
value they both give you in this case if
we say y is equal to f of t and y is
equal to h of t they'll both give you
the same y value so if when you input
some t in here into both of them so you
input the same t into both of them and
if you get the same output out of both
of them that would correspond to the
same point so we're essentially saying
where do these two functions intersect
each other and we see that they
intersect each other in two places
there's this place over here where the
coordinate is t sub 5 comma y sub 5. so
you input t sub 5 so this is t sub 5
right over here you input t sub 5 into
either function and you're going to get
you're going to get y sub 5 or another
way of writing this
another way of writing this
is f
is y sub 5 is equal to f of t sub 5
and
and y sub 5 is equal to h of t sub 5.
you see that right over there take t sub
5 evaluate your function h there you get
to y sub 5 evaluate your function f
there you get to y sub 5 or you could
say that f of t sub 5 f of t sub 5
is equal to h of t sub 5 and i'm just
writing it in a million different ways
not a million different ways but a lot
of different ways so that you get the
idea and this is the same thing as
saying of course that the natural log
of t sub 5 plus 1 is equal to
is equal to 2 e to the t sub 5 minus 1.
so this is definitely going to be true
if t is equal to t sub 5. so let me let
me just make sure that we so let me
write t sub 5 there
so t sub 5 definitely fits into this
category you put t sub 5 in there this
is going to be true and then we have
another point where these where these
two functions intersect
right over here
if you input t sub 1
into either function
t sub 1 you get y sub 1.
so once again same exact logic t sub 1
this is this is also going to be true if
t is equal to t sub 1.
so this is also going to be true for t
sub 1. so that first category we can put
t sub 5 and t sub 1.
so let me
so t sub let me make sure you can see
what i'm doing so that first category i
could put t sub 1
and i could put t sub 5. now the second
category the next category we're saying
when does 2 e to the 2 e
2 e to the t power minus 1 equal 0.
so
let's
give myself a little bit more real
estate so they're saying
when does let me draw a little line here
because it's the next category when does
e to the t minus 1 equals 0 which is
another way of saying when does h of t
equal 0
and so if
if h of t is equal to 0 and if we're
saying if we're plotting the function 8
y is equal to h of t where essentially
when does y equal h of t equals 0 or in
other words saying this when does h of t
intersect the horizontal axis when is
that that the when is that graph not
above or below it our y value here is
zero
well h of t
h of t is the blue graph and it
intercepts the t axis right over here
it intercepts the t axis right over
there we see
that h
of t sub 3
is equal to y sub 3
which is equal to zero or actually i
could even write it this way h of t sub
3 is equal to 2 e to the t sub 3 minus
1.
that's just from the definition of h of
t and that day we know that that's going
to be equal to y sub 3 which is equal to
0 y sub 3 is clearly equal to 0 we're
clearly intersecting the t axis there
so t sub 3 would fall into that second
bucket and that's the only place where
on the graph of h of t where it
intersects the t axis so t sub 3 is the
only variable i would throw into that
bucket so let's do that so i would throw
t sub 3 into this bucket and then the
last bucket we're doing the same thing
now for f of t
so
f of t is the natural log of t plus 5.
when does that intersect when does that
intersect the t-axis so this is f of t
right over here
we clearly see
right at this point
f
of t sub 2
is equal to the natural log of t sub 2
plus 5 which is equal to y sub 2
which is equal to 0. so that last bucket
this this thing natural log
natural log of t plus 5 is equal to 0.
this was that last bucket this is going
to be true for when t is equal to t sub
2. so we could throw t sub 2 in that
last bucket so let's do that t sub 2
gets to go into that last bucket and we
are done these other ones we are not
going to use i mean you can the rest of
them these are the y values that the
functions take on at those different
points and t sub
t sub 4 is kind of interesting t sub t
sub 4 is actually clearly equal to 0
because that's when we intersect the y
axis so that's i guess an interesting
point but not one of the points that
would satisfy those buckets and now we
can check our answer and we got it right